[Music]
[Music]
my name is Sonia Lupin and I'm born in
Finland and I've been with seizure but
for five years now my training from uni
is journalism I still go back to that
job by far most of the people within sea
Shepherd are volunteers even if this is
a massive global organization it's not
so much like I'm in the military or
whatever I just protect what's closest
to my heart the open ocean is a lawless
area the UN is just starting to address
that now
there's not many organizations left that
do what they do and go thousands of
miles you know trying to protect the
marine life in the waters
[Music]
just like the strength of an ecosystem
is in diversity the strength of any
movement lies in diversity so this is
why we're a volunteer organization
[Music]
and I think okay we say we could become
here with a motivation is beyond
motivation than to be committed to
something that was riot
[Music]
if you look on the earth as a spaceship
which is what it is or traveling around
the galaxy every spaceship has a life
support system and our life support
system is that biodiversity especially
in the ocean
[Music]
the land is small you know it's 30
percent of this whole planet and that's
what we think of on the land you know
but the ocean is really the planet is
the ocean the ocean provides us
everything that we need to survive
produces oxygen produces food regulates
climate temperature
[Music]
[Music]
well it gets back to that essential
mantris that if the oceans die we die
[Music]
but the the power of money and
consumption has been overriding all of
that they've always said it they were
conducting scientific research so the
International Court of Justice
underlined that they basically said that
what Whalers are doing is in fact a
fortune operation
there's not these surpluses of stuff
lying around the ocean it's all there in
the amount that it needs to be for the
ocean to live so sea Shepherd steps in
in accordance with the United Nations
world charter for nature so we enforce
international conservation law against
the
[Applause]
it's not just protests is not just
banner waving or petition signing it's
getting physically involved and making a
difference
[Music]
it's challenging the system and the
system is in favor of the bureaucracy
and when you try and stand up against
that it's it's odd the reaction you get
you are whaling illegally in these
waters you have been from death but
international fortune
to be honest if we were doing their own
thing would say shipping when we shut
down I would volunteer
[Music]
you have purposely endangered our crew
and damaged our vessels changer for
support and prevent further damage
I could stop it people just came up and
we're like what are you guys so what is
it what you're doing and it just
couldn't figure it out at all with the
chole and logos and everyone in black we
only go against illegal operators so
with authorities we do everything by the
book it's very important for us to be
recognized as a legitimate law
enforcement force and then they've never
been to sea before many of them have
never done anything like this before
the ocean is not very well at the moment
it's pretty sick and needs a lot of help
[Music]
so really what we're talking about is a
movement to save ourselves from
ourselves
[Music]
we have people who are 18 people who are
65 they're artists they're lawyers the
premier is journalists different
religious backgrounds you know and I'm
just a normal girl from a little town
[Music]
how I perceive the world everything's
connected your oceans are connected to
the land which is connected to the
people so if we keep depleting the fish
stocks with overfishing illegal fishing
there's no food for people on the planet
I do believe that every human being is
good at their heart so if you give them
the correct information they will change
and I think it's just something that I'd
be looking for the whole of my life how
I can make a direct impact for the
well-being of the planet
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Sea Shepherd can't spend the next 50
years in the Antarctic policing the
anti-whaling campaign but also the
government's can't afford it so we have
to educate the people that it's not the
right thing to do and that is the way
forwards this is almost a key moment to
join any sort of fight that is gonna try
to bring a change everything counts in
this very moment of history we're not
here to be pessimistic because we know
we've got something to say that there's
nothing to say we wouldn't be here it's
not like you get another chance of these
things you know once it's gone it's very
often that's it
[Music]
we don't try to say that CH ever is
gonna save the world or not but we can
set an example for others met a lot of
really great passionate people and it's
nice to just be part of something for
people who haven't given up hope it's
not a point where we can't move forward
positively absolutely not and I think
the fight is a good one and it's just
education
when people get to know about shisha
presence mostly you know them from TV
you know the direct actions a media can
transport quite a different image of
what this organization is about and what
we actually do people know us from the
anti-whaling campaigns in the anodic but
of course we've done a lot more and I'll
walk into a room and that would could be
another wow we didn't think you'd look
like that
[Music]
you have to work with so many different
people depending on their background
depending on their indication of their
religion their culture they're as good
as any professional crew I've ever
witnessed because they want to be there
they're not just in it for the money
this is exactly the reason why I wanted
to join Sea Shepherd using direct action
and not just witnessing illegal activity
is happening or injustice happening in
our oceans and that's what I think makes
it so strong that we can make the bond
between everybody and then work together
when there are situations that we need
to do actions
[Music]
I think it's interesting how they always
you know eco-terrorists and pirates and
all these different things and yet I
turn in my seat time to the US Coast
Guard every foot port I have to clear in
with the police since I've never
arrested you see Shepherd here the
Pirates and they stand up against
sitting you go well that's one opinion
and every pin every issue has two sides
to it
I meet a lot of young people who see
through this and they are the ones who I
think will be starting to change the
movement doesn't have any leaders when I
look around the world all the great
achievements social achievements have
been done by individuals what it brings
together people from all walks of life
older people younger people you know
some crazy people but yeah just just you
know people like you you would meet in a
day to day whatever